days after the government announced an
easing of some lockdown restrictions
traffic on the streets of Nairobi is
slowly picking up but many shops in the
center of business district remain
closed those who are reopened say
business is still bad all of a sudden
the streets went quiet after the
announcement of the lockdown and so that
is completely affected our business if I
could measure it would be about ninety
percent drop in sales the economic
crisis caused by the corona virus
outbreak is forcing hard choices not
just here in Nairobi but across Africa
many governments are struggling to find
the money to fight the pandemic and show
up their economies the World Bank and
the IMF Abbas lenders to suspend debt
payments for African countries
struggling under the covered 19 outbreak
but Chinese officials say they will deal
with African debt on a case-by-case
basis what happens next depends on China
which is not only Africa's top trading
partner but also its top lender
according to the World Bank Chinese
government and banks of land to African
governments and state owned enterprises
more than 150 billion dollars between
2010 and 2013 most of this money has
gone into the development of
infrastructure projects such as roads
railway lines and ports China is in a
bind because they want to be able to
continue to lend to Africa after COBIT
19 to make money and to influence but at
the same time they want to be able to
appear to be helping Africa at this
point in time more than 100
international nongovernmental
organizations of reinforced calls for
consideration of all debt payments in
2020 but many banks are reluctant to
risk their credit ratings and private
bondholders are unlikely to do so but
even if all that payment was suspended
this year they still trouble ahead for
African countries most collectability
a little tax and revenues have decreased
because of the lockdowns so once this
crisis is over a lot of repayments will
have to be made
Mohammed Al Jazeera Nairobi Kenya